[Musik]
herzlich willkommen zur zdf heute live
der anlass sind die aktuellen und
brisanten entwicklungen im fall der
messerattacke von dresden vor wenigen
minuten hat der generalbundesanwalt die
ermittlungen an sich gezogen
und das sagt schon einiges aus was die
brisanz angeht wir wollen nachher
darüber sprechen mit felix zimmermann
der bei uns im studio ist felix schön
dass du da bist wir werden daher
intensiv über die hintergründe sprechen
was wie wo bedeutet und natürlich auch
versuchen viele fragen zu beantworten es
stellen sich glaube ich viele fragen bei
diesem fall aber auch für den wollen wir
erstmal zurück blicken wir erinnern uns
am vierten oktober in der dresdner
innenstadt gehen abends nach dem
abendessen mitten durch die altstadt
zwei männer ein 55 jähriger krefelder
und seinen 53 jähriger begleiter aus
köln als sie auf einmal mitten in der
altstadt auf der schloßstraße
niedergestochen werden
die polizei ermittelt denn der 3 55
jährige krefelder stirbt im krankenhaus
an den verletzungen der 53 jährige
kölner überlebt die dresdner polizei
richtete eine sonderkommission
schlossstraße ein denn in dieser straße
passierte die messerattacke nun die neue
entwicklung gestern wird ein 20 jähriger
syrer von der dresdner polizei
festgenommen heute hat die
staatsanwaltschaft dresden gegen ihn
haftbefehl erlassen er kommt in
untersuchungshaft und wie gesagt vor
wenigen minuten hat der
generalbundesanwalt die ermittlungen an
sich gezogen
sprechen wir mit unserer reporterin in
dresden cornelia schiemenz cornelia was
weiß man denn bisher überhaupt über
diesen 20 jährigen syrer der gestern
festgenommen wurde
ja hallo ins studio so richtig viel weiß
man noch nicht der junge mann wird zur
stunde befragt vernommen und dann
erhoffen wir uns alle noch ein bisschen
mehr details er ist wohl seit 2015 in
deutschland erlebt hier und zwar als
geduldete asylbewerber und er hat auch
schon einiges ich sage jetzt mal ganz
salopp auf dem kerbholz er ist erheblich
vorbestraft und verbrauch
achtet die letzten zwei monate zwei
jahre und neun monate in einer
jugendvollzug strafanstalt und zwar hier
in regis-breitingen einer kleinen stadt
in sachsen der jury wurde verurteilt
wegen tätlichen angriffen auf vollzugs
verstrickung beamten vor allem aber weil
bei ihm vermutet wurde und beweise
gefunden worden dass er geworben hat für
unterstützer und um mitglieder einer
terroristischen vereinigung im ausland
er zeigte sich wohl begeistert vom
dschihad in sozialen medien
und das ist wohl nun auch der grund
warum der generalbundesanwalt die
ermittlungen an sich genommen hat weil
eben im raum steht dass hier eine
islamistisch geprägte tat vorliegt der
20 jährige syrer
der war erst seit wenigen tagen auf
freiem fuß ganz exakt wurde am 29
september aus der haft entlassen
und nur wenig später kam es eben jetzt
zu diesem tragischen überfall wo er
offenbar der täter riss der die beiden
touristen aus nordrhein-westfalen
unvermittelt völlig unvermittelt in der
dresdner innenstadt mit einem messer
angegriffen hat wobei eine im nachgang
starb warum er das gemacht hat das ist
jetzt völlig offen und davon erhoffen
wir jetzt in den nächsten tagen noch
weitere aufklärung könnten ja vielen
vielen dank für diese frische
informationen aus dresden
ja felix der generalbundesanwalt hat
diese attacke die ermittlungen was
diesen fall angeht an sich gezogen was
bedeutet dass grundsätzlich
grundsätzlich bedeutet dass
generalbundesanwalt wird immer tätig
wenn die innere oder äußere sicherheit
deutschlands gefährdet ist durch eine
tat entdeckt man jetzt hier gut ein
messerangriff das gefährt ja nicht
gleich die innere sicherheit aber es ist
auch so beim mord und totschlag wenn das
gesamt gepräge
dafür spricht dass hier eine
radikalislamistische hintergrund ist und
das gesamt gepräge von einer besonderen
gefährlichkeit ausgehe dann kann der
generalbundesanwalt die ermittlungen an
sich ziehen und das ist hier geschehen
die bundesjustizministerin christine
lambrecht hat heute erklärt das
schreckliche tötungsdelikt in dresden
hat nach dem stand der
mit lungen also vorsichtig formuliert
einen islamistischen hintergrund und der
bundesinnenminister geht in die gleiche
richtung er sagt bundesinnenminister
seehofer der tödliche angriff auf zwei
touristen in dresden vor knapp drei
wochen hatte offenbar einen
radikalislamistischen hintergrund man
mitgefühl gilt den hinterbliebenen die
neben dem verlust heute erfahren mussten
dass die morde vermutlich politisch
motiviert waren die tat führt uns erneut
die gefährlichkeit islamistische gewalt
vor augen also das geht klar in eine
richtung und unsere kollegin conny hat
es gerade erzählt der hintergrund
sozusagen die die vorgeschichte des 20
jährigen syrer das ist ja schon
erheblich wenn man mit dem er
sympathisiert leute mitglieder an wird
und sogar eine eine straftat terror
verbrechen eine gewalttat geplant
ja absolut das sind aber alles so
terroristische vorfeld taten dafür gibt
es keine riesige freiheitsstrafe denn es
ist ja nichts konkretes passiert sondern
was eben passiert ist weil hier eben
versucht der anwerbung von mitgliedern
für den es einerseits und andererseits
zum beispiel das herunterladen einer
bauanleitung für eine bombe ja und da
gibt es natürlich gewisse grenzen der
wurde hier verurteilt insgesamt für
seine taten von drei jahre und dieser
haftstrafe hat er auch voll verbüßt
und wenn man uns zwar zu
jugendstrafrecht und wenn man bedenkt
dass jemand im gefängnis eine
jugendstrafe absetzt und die voll
verbüßt das ist sehr selten schon mal
kein gutes zeichen was die einschätzung
der behörden im hinblick auf die
gefährlichkeit angeht also würde sagen
im normalfall wenn ein jugendlicher
etwas ja also ich mal an stellt
verurteilt wird bei guter führung wurde
er meistens doch früher entlassen um
sozusagen wieder zu resozialisieren
absolut genau da wird besonders drauf
geguckt was können wir machen gibt es
möglichkeiten ja dass man jemanden
vorläufig gewissen zweiten freilässt
arbeiten lässt irgendwas und ist sich
alles nicht passiert die gesamte strafe
verbüßt und da ist natürlich auch keine
verlängerung dann möglich bei solchen
vorstrafen da muss mann freigelassen
werden und dann ist die frage weiter zu
stellen
wie wird denn so jemand der hier als
gefährder offenbar galt weiter behandelt
jetzt ist zu lesen dass er hat es
kollege der stadt ist bereits gesagt
erst am 29 september gerade erst
entlassen worden wieder auf freiem fuß
und stand seither unter führungsaufsicht
was heißt das denn man fragt sich ja hat
man denn an solchen menschen nicht
weiter auf dem radar gehabt
führungsaufsicht meint eine maßregel zur
sicherung und besserung das bedeutet zb
das einem täter nach verbüßung der tat
ein bewährungshelfer an die hand gegeben
wird der die aufgabe hat zu schauen dass
der auch resozialisiert also das
bedeutet jetzt nicht dass ein polizist
ständig hinterherrennen eine weitere
straftat zu fällen das bedeutet das
nicht aber es war eben auch als
gefährder eingestuft und da muss ich
jetzt das landeskriminalamt fragen
lassen was ist denn da geschehen ich
habe vorhin mal angerufen wollte fragen
ja war dennoch auf dem radar
für wie gefährlich wurde eingestuft und
meine fragen wurden abgeblockt aber
diese fragen wird das lka irgendwann mal
jetzt beantworten müssen
denn offensichtlich wurde er jetzt nicht
intensiv überwacht es gibt täter die
wenn die ganz besonders gefährlich
eingestuft werden wirklich intensiv
überwacht wurden und ob das hier der
fall ist das wissen wir das noch nicht
also viele fragen die noch zu klären
sind wir haben einige kommentare und
fragen silke motzen becker schreibt zb
sagt glasklar sie urteilt das war kein
tragischer überfall sondern ein
geplanter mord und einen zu y de
schreibt weshalb wird der täter
weiterhin in deutschland und europa
geduldet wenn er doch schon mehrmals
straffällig geworden ist also es ist ein
asylbewerber aus syrien der durchaus in
deutschland geduldet ist das heißt also
er konnte sich frei zu recht nach
verbüßung der haftstrafe in dresden
bewegen aber da frage ich mich auch mit
diesem vorstrafenregister unter nach dem
ganzen warum wird jemand nicht
abgeschoben oder warum kann er sich frei
bewegen und meines wissens nach wird
nach syrien eben ein bürgerkriegsland
aktuell nicht abgeschoben so dass
wahrscheinlich diese möglichkeit
entfallen ist
näheres ist jetzt hier war noch nicht
bekannt aber noch syrien wird nicht
abgeschoben
und wenn er dieses freiheitsstrafe
verbüßt hat dann muss er eben auch
freigelassen werden
ja das ist dann kann man nicht jemanden
ins gefängnis stecken weil nicht
abgeschoben werden kann
das ist der grund dafür wo es passiert
ja ständig dass gewalttäter verurteilte
gewalttäter direkt nach der haft
abgeschoben werden hier waren dafür
offensichtlich die voraussetzungen nicht
gegeben
ja wir haben weitere zuschriften als ein
syrer der in dresden wohnt macht mir
sowas viel angst schreibt über youtube
bln 365 als ein syrer der dresden wohnt
macht mir so etwas viel angst einerseits
angst vor kriminellen und terroristen
andererseits vor rechtsextremisten und
wie sie darauf reagieren werden
man kann nur ahnen und hoffen dass es
eben nicht größere wellen schlägt was
wieder in die andere richtung geht
ja das ist immer das was teilweise im
befürchte wird diese spirale der gewalt
ja das ist ja auch das was man mal hört
wenn versuche gemacht werden
islamistische anschläge zu provozieren
es gibt ja diesen ein
bundeswehr-offizier dem das vorgeworfen
wird dann passiert das ja aus dem
gedanken heraus dass eine spirale der
gewalt entsteht gegen gewalt und soweit
es erhoffen sich ja sogar viele
rechtsextremer so etwas
und das ist natürlich so eine so eine
tat immer ein schreckensszenario gerade
für syrer die hier leben und die
natürlich zu 99,9999 prozent also völlig
friedliche mit uns leben
ein hinweis über youtube und schreibt
jemand ist nicht vor ein paar tagen erst
jemand auf der straße enthauptet worden
er spielt an auf den fall in frankreich
wo ein lehrer getötet worden ist auch
islamischer hintergrund ich dachte die
gefahr kommt von rechts ist es so dass
man vielleicht jetzt lange zeit auch
sozusagen den terror von
islamistische seite wieder etwas
verdrängt hat ist er etwas aus dem fokus
vielleicht gekommen der ist aus dem
fokus gekommen weil immer auch viel
weniger passiert ist der es ist
zerschlagen und das hat sich durch auch
ausgewirkt es gibt eben viel weniger
anschläge und auch weniger versuchte
anschläge
wir dürfen aber nicht vergessen die
ermittler haben ja auch viele anschläge
immer wieder mal vereitelt und da gibt
es natürlich nicht so große berichte
darüber dass erledigt sich dann von
selbst aber zu dem kommentar ich dachte
die gefahr kommt von rechts ich dachte
der gefahr des islamistischen eine
schließt das andere nicht aus
beides ist gefährlich und man kann nicht
so verengt ag und sagen das ist die
gefordert dies gibt dem meer gefahren so
einfach ist die antwort eigentlich auf
diese frage
wir haben eben den bundesinnenminister
zitiert der eben sagt die tat führt uns
erneut die gefährlichkeit islamistischer
gewalt vor augen ich glaube da ist das
im grunde genommen bereits eine antwort
dann haben wir weitere fragen
hier schreibt jemand regie nack die
meisten syrer sind christen also heißt
es nicht gleich dass er moslem ist im
grunde genommen wissen wir bisher noch
nichts über den syrer welcher religion
er angehört et cetera oder was mit ihm
in syrien passiert ist das sind viele
fragen wahrscheinlich die offen sind
wichtig aber da er ja dem werbung für
den es gemacht hat dürfte es relativ
nahe liegend sein dass jetzt kein christ
war und der generalbundesanwalt
ermittelt der dann nicht umsonst sondern
weil sie eben von den radikal
islamistischen hintergrund ausgeht was
angesichts der historie dieses mannes
eben äußerst naheliegend ist dass diese
tat damit in verbindung steht
grundsätzliche frage an dich felix wie
sind denn die weiteren schritte was
bedeutet das wir haben andere fälle in
der vergangenheit gehabt wenn du uns
erklärt was sind jetzt die nächsten
schritte heute wie gesagt die
ankündigung aus karlsruhe der
generalbundesanwalt die ermittlungen an
sich was heißt das jetzt ganz konkret
eigentlich das heißt konkret ermittelt
er ist quasi die zuständige
staatsanwaltschaft und kann dann immer
wieder zurückgreifen auf polizei vor ort
um natürliche zum beispiel ermittlungen
genau durchzuführen und dann prüft der
generalbundesanwalt ob nicht nur an
fox verdacht soll ein sogenannter
hinreichender tatverdacht vorliegt das
bedeutet die wahrscheinlichkeit einer
verurteilung ist größer als 50 prozent
dann wird er wahrscheinlich auch noch
mal ein haftbefehl zusätzlich beantragen
ja und dann wird eben anklage erhoben
das sind dann die nächsten schritte die
bei diesen solchen ermittlungen folgen
aber diese soko schlossstraße sozusagen
die dresdner werden weiter ermitteln
allerdings hat sozusagen das heft des
handelns der generalbundesanwalt in der
hand ja ob das dann noch unter dem
gleichen namen fungiert das ist offen
der generalbundesanwalt kann das
entscheiden wen er wie beauftragt mit
den ermittlungen aber ist äußerst
wahrscheinlich dass natürlich die
lokalen behörden lokalen ermittler
weiter mit beschäftigt sich mit dem fall
felix vielen vielen dank für die
erklärungen erläuterungen und
informationen wir werden das ganze
weiter verfolgen denn wir haben es
bereits gesagt es sind viele fragen und
wir werden wohl hoffentlich noch viele
antworten bekommen felix hat es bereits
gesagt es gibt noch viele fragen die
offen sind und wo die behörden eben auch
antworten geben werden wir fassen noch
einmal zusammen es tut im grunde
genommen die justizministerin die gesagt
hat dass die tödliche attacke in dresden
wohl trauriger weise dem stand der
ermittlungen nach einen islamistischen
hintergrund hat offenbar als ist das
eben dann auch der grund warum der
generalbundesanwalt heute die
ermittlungen an sich gezogen hat es ist
die tat gewesen in dresden am vierten
oktober
wir fassen noch einmal zusammen dass
dort eben zwei touristen niedergestochen
worden sind einer ist dabei umgekommen
ein 55 jähriger krefelder der 53 jährige
kölner hat überlebt tage lang hat man
gerätselt was der hintergrund warum es
zu dieser attacke gekommen ist und nun
mit der festnahme eines 20-jährigen
syrers gestern dem haftrichter
vorgeführt worden ist und nun in
untersuchungshaft sitzt verdichten sich
die hinweise dass ist eben eine
islamistische tat in dresden war so
weiter stand der dinge für danke ihnen
ganz herzlich fürs zuschauen und sagen
tschüss und schönen abend noch